E aí
[Música]
o Olá o meu nome é Fábio Inácio tem 35
anos e vem de uma pequena Aldeia chamada
mas era no concelho de Torres Vedras
e as 14 anos comecei a prática água de
boa e aí nasceu o meu faxina pelo amor
muito por culpa das firmas quase agora
podia Austrália Indonésia Havaí e por
isso agora sonhava lá viajar com meu
grupo de amigos mas ao mesmo tempo sabia
porque assim a sociedade me ensinou
desde pequeno e viajar era só para os
outros que existe todo um tipo de
Barreiras que nos impedem expor ao mundo
afora sejam elas financeiras sociais
culturais ou até mesmo ideias
pré-concebidas estacionar segredo das
Comunidades 15.000 descemos acabei o
secundário e por opção nós ir para a
universidade andei de trabalho ele
trabalha está descobriram me sentia bem
até que fui convidado por um grande
amigo meu para ir com ela e com as três
cervejas até a Indonésia a minha função
era fotografar coisa comecei a fazer os
anos antes por paixão esta arte de
contar histórias através de imagens
aceitei o desafio e lá fui eu feliz da
vida ainda sem saber que embarcar numa
viagem que viria a mudar a minha vida
para sempre
a incômoda olha neste mês tivemos talvez
três a quatro dias de ondas quase quase
que só seja perfeitas para o surfe assim
em vez de passar todo o tempo a
fotografar e eles a surfar como estava
planeado para ser grande parte do tempo
a socializar com outros ter filhos por
lá andavam e principalmente com os
habitantes locais da pequena Vila de
cruz onde era o nosso alojamento ao
caminhar pelas ruas mercados Campos de
cultivo ao ver a maneira como essas
comunidades viviam as suas diferenças
deste nome cujas linguísticas e
religiosas fiquei completamente
Encantado até o som da coluna de
mosquito é chamar os fiéis para a reza
que ficava mesmo ao lado do meu quarto e
me acordava assim horas da manhã e fez
sentir mais próximo da cultura deste
povo Ok se calhar tens de gerar um
cadinho acordar todas as vezes que da
manhã que o cabelo todo não deixa nada
assassinado
bom e foi ao ver todas essas novas
paisagens diferentes formas de
diferentes formas culturais que me
apercebi de tudo que muito tempo
descobrir aprender percebi que queria de
facto e ver e fotografar o mundo
aproximar das mais diferentes culturas e
pelo caminho derrubar as barreiras que
tantas vezes me faziam pensar que viajar
era só para os outros pois esta viagem a
Indonésia e comecei a tirar um curso
profissional de fotografia e a trabalhar
ao mesmo tempo tipo de fazer dois então
seus pela Europa sozinho para ver como
sentia e com me adaptar a esta nova
forma de viajar sozinho e sem estar
preso a nada depois ficar em casa as
pessoas locais para a minha aproximar da
cultura do sítio digitável e desta forma
integral nessas comunidades
e depois essas viagens pensei para mim
mesmo agora agora vou dar a volta ao
mundo sabia que ia conhecer o mundo numa
viagem 18 meses e depois quando voltasse
Ia publicar um livro fotografia sobre
essa viagem e mais uma vez feliz da vida
lá fui eu porque ia para começar seguir
deverão aquele país é que foi mesmo
acontecer nada não ele por ser perigoso
e os meus pais e amigos também por muito
do que na comunicação social no entanto
o irão é até os dias de hoje o meu peixe
preferido em termos pessoas lá em 23 nós
não paguei uma única noite toda a gente
na rua queria falar comigo levavam para
a sua casa davam de comer sítio para
tomar banho e dormir quando eu queria ir
para outra localidade toda a gente
conhece alguém que morava lá e tratavam
de tudo para chegar em segurança aqui
sente que eles estavam ser
verdadeiramente genuínos que davam por
gostava de ajudar e não por querer nada
em troca Ou melhor queria mostrar que
nossa comum diz Nós não somos de cores
como dizem os vossos países ou viver sem
e ali sente amor e não foi pouco
e depois disso ainda ele volta à
Indonésia Malásia e Tailândia por fora
era para ser 18 meses mas acabaram por
servir tinha feito um plano que morreu a
segunda médico decidir por bem e sem
planos sem estar preso nada quando
estava se vemos estavam era que vais
ficar a uma semana interna é só que
estiveste numa pequena Aldeia sem uma
história para visitar para mim viajar
não é apenas fotografar e ver por fora
aos todos o a distância nada disso
viajar é viver aprender e partilhar
encontrar uma real proximidade com as
pessoas locais e deixar de olhar para
elas como se fossem diferentes por na
realidade não são assim tão diferentes
de mim nem de ti longas viagens conviver
com tribos indígenas e povos novas coisa
que só tinha visto Nacional geográfico
mas que são seres humanos como nós A
única diferença é que ainda vivem em
perfeita Harmonia com a natureza em que
fazem troca de mantimentos e serviços
onde todos se ajudam conhecer por
exemplo o povo falta eles vivem no meio
das montanhas e florestas do Nepal
O Silas é a madeira e vão às vezes
trocar por comida normalmente Chile a
rosto quando já não tem madeira boa para
trabalhar ao pé do seu complemento
morrendo localização e assim vivem 365
dias por ano ao viver em Vilas Humildes
formas da natureza com o povo não
queremos desapego por Bens Materiais
somos mais grandes ao que temos
começamos a pôr em perspectiva muitos
dos nossos problemas e as flores azuis e
estamos mais focados no amor ao próximo
e isso é bom muito bom de quando toda a
certeza se só pudesse fazer uma viagem
na vida escolhi a gente que hoje é o
país que mais me fascina e onde voltei
vezes 50 é um mundo dentro de um ano e
na Índia everything is próxima dizem
isso é tão verdade em um advogado me fez
sentir tão desconfortável com ainda nas
primeiras 24 anos mas depois disse em
outro lugar me fez sentir tão conectada
sentir sempre como se tivessem qualquer
outra parte do mundo em casa feliz tem
que eu completamente conectado com o
local nunca pensei que um ser estranho
e é ter sentimento que eu também era
sair
eu posso dizer muito intensamente por 20
meses voltei a casa ou melhor a Portugal
porque depois de tanto tempo é difícil
chamar casal só lugar tranquilo feliz e
com certeza daqui há tanta gente boa
nesse mundo a chegar às continuaram Mas
desejo de fazer algo diferente mais à
frente começou a aparecer e aí com toda
a naturalidade voltou a surgir na minha
mente um sonho anti caminhar o Pacific
Crest Trail e quem diria que eu iria ser
o primeiro português daqui assistir a
fazer essa caminhada Então o que é o
pacificar Extra O classificar astral o
PCP como é conhecido é um trilho
pedestre e equestre nos Estados Unidos
da América que liga as fronteiras do
México a do Canadá ao longo mais 4.200
km demora em média cinco meses a ser
completo grande parte do caminho foi
longe da civilização no meio de
florestas montanhas lagos e do exame
e o meu grande objetivo esperar essa
viagem era aprender mais sobre o meu
corpo descobrir quais eram os meus
limites e perceber se os conseguia
superar andar uma distância tão grande
num curto espaço tempo a tudo o que se
espera liberar as costas algumas vezes
cansado com fome e frio número
desconhecido de mais esta viagem como ao
Master classe sobre o meu corpo como uma
viagem normal
e lembro-me do dia em que estava sentado
no momento do PCP na fronteira com o
Canadá e posso dizer que foi uma das
Sensações mais Midas ter na vida ali
começou a chover e por duas semanas a
chuva fez parte do caminho mas primeiros
dias e acertei tranquilo a fim de uma
semana deixou de ser tão engraçado
montar e desmontar a tenda a chuva não
conseguir parar para comer por tinha as
mãos completamente congeladas E também
porque tinha medo de entrar no com a
temia senti-me completamente miserável
mesmo nunca pensei em desistir já estava
à espera que estive coisas piores que
você conhecer Como disse antes o
objetivo era mesmo a superação Vem esta
viagem como se fosse um dia normal da
minha vida que na verdade até normal
porque é isso que eu tenho feito nos
últimos anos e quando acontece alguma
eles vão no dia a dia eu não desisti
tenta adaptar mais situação em que me
encontro e continuar a viver os desafios
eram constantes e não estavam limitados
apenas as condições extremas é que foi
exposto o caminho era rico em vida
selvagem nos Estados Unidos há dois
tipos de
e vai ser preto ao castanho e outro
segredo que é castanho também sabia que
se fosse atacado por um deles tinha que
lutar para sobreviver E se fosse atacado
pelo outro dia de fingir que estava a
ser estava morto mesmo que ele estivesse
à dentadas no pescoço até ele ficar faz
brincar de ir embora olha o fato
engraçado é que eu não sabia de estender
eu mais engraçado ainda foi Teve sim
curso durante a do caminho e na sempre
estava sozinho o mais marcante deste
Quais foi o último mãe e filho gente
e ela acabar é subir em cima curvinha
cabeça para baixo isso é
Oi amor vai para frente ao mesmo se deve
a correr EA maior da mãe Bernardo olhar
para mim meu corpo parou aquele que ele
vai ter entre ficar tá agora aperta que
era curva 10 metros e curva e ela estava
alimentos e as mulheres de mim que ele
ficar ela quatro patas no chão só ficou
atrás olha para mim eu já disse nada a
cada vez olha para onde o silêncio e foi
indicado duas vezes lá em cima nos
momentos em
eu tive também os dias em que sentir
mais embaixo psicologicamente É verdade
em que estive Algumas Noites sem
conseguir dormir e várias horas a chorar
compulsivamente comecei a questionar
tudo sobre a minha vida à espera já
sobre a vida dos outros do universo
sentimos sétimo quase de volta a idade
dos porquês andar 12 a 13 horas por dia
sozinho alguns dias 40 Km pontos mais de
80 tanto o corpo como a mente que estão
fortemente relacionados é que a um
preciso dar uma das coisas que me as
donas meu caminho foram as pessoas
ferrar a vez no caminho todo tem que
esperar mais do que cinco minutos por
uma Belém toda a gente vai haver estava
nos supermercados todos vinham falar
comigo na rua todos que tem um para
contar histórias de e sempre compre nos
olhos nutre quando estava na centro da
Califórnia a chover as Serras fiz muitas
passagens de montanhas a mais de 3.000
metros uma mais quatro meses e ele era
eu que os olhos a brilhar
e nessa altura disse para mim mesmo Fabi
isso que estás a fazer É mesmo muito
bonito mesmo muito bonito eu mando as
viagens que muita gente diz que é
preciso ter coragem para fazer o que eu
faço que elas não conseguiam que eu sou
uma inspiração entre outras coisas
sinceramente Nunca entendi bem isso
porque isso é uma coisa que eu quero
fazer para mim é normal fazer ou pelo
menos tentar fazer aquilo que apesar de
estar lindo meus tios vida nunca não
quer dizer muito valor
é isso meu caro auxiliar Serras que
temos de valorizar mais ter orgulho no
que fazemos e apesar de não devemos
fazer nada pelos outros se os
conseguimos respirar em desenhar em
todas as viagens que faz aparecer novas
lições nomeadamente a ser minha a pessoa
ou pelo menos Quero acreditar nisso tem
uma ideia totalmente erradas Americanas
pensa que são os donos do mundo não
precisa estar mais errados por todas as
pequenas Vilas passei fosse vir com o
mesmo amor que foi o seguir numa pequena
Vila de verão da Mongólia da birmânia ou
mesmo na masseira de ondulação natural
acredito realmente que consegui
encontrar a casa do outro lado uma
E aí
[Música]